[Musik]
es ist geschehen wie vorhergesagt am
wohl gefährlichsten ort der welt und dem
wohl hoffnungslosesten kabul flughafen
am frühen abend ortszeit zwei
explosionen sollen mindestens 13
menschen getötet haben und dutzende
verletzt ein selbstmordattentäter habe
seine bombenweste
zündet ein weiterer attentäter an einem
nahe gelegenen hotel
westliche geheimdienste haben vor solch
einem szenario gewarnt anschläge nicht
von den taliban sondern von ihren
feinden dem afghanischen ableger des
sogenannten s wer genau hinter den
angriffen von heute steckt noch unklar
wir kennen noch nicht alle einzelheiten
aber die terroristen haben auf menschen
gezielt die vor den flughafen toren
gewartet haben und auf ihre ausreise
hoffen sie wollen sicherheit und
freiheit für sich und deshalb ist dies
ein absolut niederträchtiger anschlag in
einem nach sehr sehr angespannten
situation neue gewalt an dem tag an dem
die militärische luftbrücke wohl
endgültig abbrechen wird auch die
bundeswehr flug heute das letzte mal
menschen aus für die vielen
verzweifelten die rings um den flughafen
weiter auf rettung hoffen wird der
smarten immer hoffnungsloser
zurückgelassen an einem der
gefährlichsten orte der welt
guten abend zu diesem zdf spezial
sehr viele menschen in sehr großer not
dazu zeitdruck eine supermacht und ihre
verbündeten auf dem rückzug die einen
wünschen sich dass sie möglichst schnell
verschwinden
andere hoffen noch irgendwie mit
rauszukommen und all das am nadelöhr
flughafen kabul das allein ist schon
eine explosive mischung aber es sollte
heute noch schlimmer kommen wir haben
uns gesehen auf dem kundig detonierten
zwei bomben die kanzlerin geht von
selbstmordattentätern aus das pentagon
hat soeben bestätigt auch mehrere us
soldaten sind unter den opfern
wie es aussieht und zu geht jetzt den
kabul darüber habe ich kurz vor der
sendung mit dem journalisten franz marty
gesprochen
guten abend franz marty beginnen wir mit
dem was ist wie erleben sie diesen abend
in kabul
heute abend ist es zu einem anschlag
gekommen in kabul am
flughafen.de teilzunehmen noch unklar es
scheint aber mindestens zwei explosionen
gegeben zu haben wahrscheinlich von
männern von selbstmordattentaten die
sich da in den massen versteckt haben
sich den weg dorthin gebaut hatten an
den flughafen wo tausende afghanen
untersuchen auf einen flieger zu kommen
um massnahmen evaluieren zu werden
ads explosion bau eines tores zum
flughafen die zweite neue eines
gesicherten hotels das unweit dieses
tores war und es wird von dutzenden von
von getöteten und verwundeten berichtet
das pentagon hat auch bestätigt dass es
dann auch zumindest kurz zu einem
feuergefecht zwischen angreifern und
sicherheitspersonal gekommen sein soll
die deutsche verteidigungsministerin und
andere haben sehr eindringlich gewarnt
heute vor anschlägen offenkundig gab es
konkrete hinweise dass heute was
passiert
es gab schon seit einigen tagen
warnungen mir wurde auch gestern von
einer quelle bestätigt die in kontakt
steht mit mitglied und selbst einen
islamischen staates dass diese
splittergruppe ausbauen könnte
ist immer schwierig zu sagen weil im
kongo gibt es eigentlich immer oft
optisch immer wohnungen dass etwas
passieren könnte
dieses mal hat es konkrete anzeichen
gegeben um die ist es leider auch zu
diesem anschlag gekommen wenn man solche
anschläge nicht verhindern kann was ist
die konsequenz noch früher diese
rettungsflüge beenden aber heißt das
dann nicht dem terror nachzugeben
ja das problem ist wirklich es gibt hier
keine gute lösung
komplette sicherheit vor allem in einer
solchen lage wie sie es am flughafen ist
mit tausenden von leuten da kann nicht
jeder kontrolliert werden was man
dagegen machen kann ist schwierig zu
sagen wenn man versucht die leute vom
flughafen weg zu bringen
werden die einfach trotzdem versuchen an
anderen und frieden mauern und dann
könnten dort anschläge geschehen also
und der sicherungsmaßnahmen verlagern
eigentlich nur das problem und
evakuierungsflüge vollständig
auszusetzen ist natürlich auch schwierig
viele der leute die am flughafen bauen
die wussten kunden warnungen aber die
sagten die gefahr in afghanistan zu
bleiben ist mindestens so groß wie die
gefahr einzugehen um flughafen ziel
eines anschlages zu werden wie groß
schätzen sie denn die gefahr für die
bevölkerung unter den taliban
tatsächlich ein
das hängt vom einzelfall ab bisher ist
sorgen dass es keine anzeichen gibt dass
die taliban flächendeckend
vergeltungsmaßnahmen gegen die
bevölkerung ausgeführt hätten oder gegen
ehemalige sicherheitskräfte es haut
fälle gegeben von tötungen
grauenvolle ereignisse abheben dass sich
massenverhaftungen oder
massenexekutionen und die taliban
betonen immer wieder dass eine
generalamnestie gibt gewisse leute sind
gefährdet andere bei anderen ist es auch
so dass sie panisch sind und die
effektive gefahr wohl überschätzen
vielen dank nach kabul franz marty
die taliban hatten die macht das vakuum
das der westen seit seinem rückzug
hinterlassen hat innerhalb kürzester
zeit zu füllen die afghanische armee die
strukturen die man dachte aufgebaut zu
haben waren nicht mehr als ein
kartenhaus aber haben die taliban auch
die macht das land zu führen es wirklich
zu lenken und dafür zu sorgen dass eine
regierung tun muss astra delgado über
das was die taliban mal waren und jetzt
gefragt sind zu sein
sie sind wieder an der macht doch sie
sind nicht mehr die gleichen wie vor 20
jahren so zumindest ihre botschaft sie
versprechen schulbildung für mädchen
berufsrecht für frauen eine
generalamnestie die taliban 2.0 modernen
harmlos medienaffine doch die angst in
der eigenen bevölkerung sitzt tief als
sie 1996 nach blutigen kämpfen in
afghanistan die macht an sich reißen
beginnt eine schreckensherrschaft mit
öffentlichen hinrichtungen sie gelten
als ultra religiös konservativ
gewaltbereit als nach dem 11 september
klar wird die taliban haben
internationale terroristen wie al qaida
unterstützt wendet sich das blatt eine
internationale koalition unter der
führung der usa besetzt afghanistan die
taliban verschwinden zwar aus dem
rampenlicht doch ein neuer gegner zeigt
sich die terror miliz islamischer staat
mit den taliban verbindet sie ihr
radikaler glaube die ablehnung
westlicher werte doch ihre mittel sind
noch brutaler als die die taliban
während der es in seinem kampf weltweit
anschläge ausführt zielen die taliban
vorwiegend aus afghanistan ab ihre wahre
stärke unterschätzter westen bis zum 15
august als sie kabul einnehmen so sexy
das ist noch kein sieg aber es zeigt
ganz klar die schwäche der amerikaner
und alle anderen länder die truppen in
afghanistan haben
wie stark die von pakistan unterstützten
taliban sind ist nach wie vor unklar ob
sie sich von ihren einst zu radikalen
zielen wirklich abgewendet haben dieser
beweis steht in afghanistan noch aus
per skype bin ich verbunden mit
professor hans-joachim gießmann sie sind
ehemaliger direktor der berghof stiftung
und sie haben die verhandlungen in doha
begleitet als berater guten abend
wir müssen lernen und sind unsererseits
gut beraten zu verstehen es gibt nicht
die taliban sondern wer hat da welche
interessen
gibt verschiedene strömungen innerhalb
der bewegung die sich in den vergangenen
jahren haus geprägt haben wir haben die
religiösen führer die vor allem pakistan
sitzen wir haben das politische büro des
vor allem über die verhandlungen indoor
bekannt geworden ist wir haben die
kämpfer die im lande in den letzten
jahren sich verstärkt haben und
neu zur bewegung gestoßen sind und wir
haben schließlich die alten führer
versuchen auch in der bewegung weiterhin
eine rolle zu spielen noch ist nicht
klar wer hinter diesen anschlägen heute
steckt aber klar ist sie haben
interessen diejenigen die dahinter
stecken welche sind das aus ihrer sicht
das sind interessen jener die versuchen
die gegenwärtige situation der
instabilität für sich auszunutzen und
zusätzliche unruhe in den prozess zu
bringen ich glaube nicht dass die
attentäter in den reihen der taliban zu
kämpfen zu finden sind die eher
interesse daran haben die situation
unter kontrolle zu bringen er muss er
befürchtet werden dass anhänger des
islamischen staates oder von al kaida in
den letzten wochen und tagen das chaos
in kabul genutzt haben und zum flughafen
vorzudringen und dort ihre anschläge zu
verüben was heißt das jetzt für die
anstehenden internationalen
verhandlungen wenn es die taliban nicht
gibt wer es dann der ansprechpartner
und die taliban hatten in der
vergangenheit die möglichkeit ihre
spannungen dadurch zu überbrücken dass
sie einen einheitlichen feind hatten die
regierung afghanistans und sie waren
auch einig in dem ziel der ausländischen
truppen aus afghanistan heraus zu
bringen jetzt geht es um die zukunft des
staates und hier wird sich zeigen
welche strömung sich durchsetzt und was
jedem augenblick erleben ist eine
diskrepanz zwischen der bereitschaft der
erklärten bereitschaft der taliban eine
inklusive regierung anzustreben und
gleichzeitig der besetzung der ersten
positionen mit ausschließlich mullahs
aus dem rathaus den paschtunischen
kreisen der taliban also von inklusive
ist im augenblick noch nichts mehr zu
sehen und was heißt das wiederum für
afghanistan für die menschen dort
situation wird vorläufig instabil
bleiben
er ist hängt alles davon ab wie schnell
die taliban in der lage sind ein
funktionsfähiges regierungssystem
übrigens nicht nur in kabul sondern
ganzen land zu entwickeln und die
elementaren versorgungsprobleme des
landes in den griff zu bekommen
die humanitäre situation wird sich mit
sicherheit weiter verschlechtern
afghanistan hängt am tropf
internationaler hilfen das gilt auch für
die taliban und das ist möglicherweise
auch eine ein zugang zu den taliban sie
dazu zu bewegen mehr
menschenrechte zu achten und hilfen zu
zuzulassen wie vor allem den menschen in
ihrer humanitären notlage zu gute kommen
professor hans-joachim gießmann vielen
dank für diese einblicke und
informationen
die bundeswehr hört heute auf
rettungsflüge durchzuführen alle
deutschen soldaten sind raus am 31
august werden dann auch die letzten
amerikanischen soldaten afghanistan
verlassen haben das ist kommende woche
dienstag wir werden also schon sehr bald
zeuge davon werden wie es bestellt ist
um das was die taliban versprochen haben
und das was dem land tatsächlich wieder
erfährt
wir wünschen ihnen noch einen guten
abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]